and they started to figure out a way to
storage much more energy when they mixed
each other and they used each other the
minerals you mean mixed the minerals
yeah the minerals so they created this
this link that we call love which is
basically the exchange of energy
the exchange of energy to one another is
the pulse the constant pulse of
exchanging different amounts of energy
to one another so I have a lot of energy
you have less energy let's share that
energy and that
it's love when you become more conscious
you need a lot of energy so you will
need people that has the same amount of
energy or higher in order to transcend
this to the next step that's why we
break up
it's like you you need to keep changing
because you need to exchange different
kinds of energy to to keep evolving